il pousse des cris pour attirer
l'attention des femelles pendant la
saison des amours et intimider les
autres mâles on parle évidemment du SER
Hélène oui focus ce soir sur le Bram du
SER une période où d'impressionnant
rugissement raésonne dans nos forêts une
saison à des amours qui durent un mois
environ entre la mi-septembre et la
mi-novembre Faustine luno a posé sa
caméra au sein du domaine national de
chambor pour essayer de capter ce moment
insolite
regardez c'est un spectacle auquel peu
ont la chance d'assister un combat de
seréf en pleine période de rute à
l'observatoire de chambor le point de
vue est idéal en hauteur caché derrière
un filet de camouflage les curieux
arrivé à l'aube observe le balai des
servid avec la plus grande discrétion
j'en ai vu trois et on en entendait un
4è plus loin donc pas déçu vous repartez
avec des souvenirs ah tout à fait je les
ai mis en boîte on va voir ce que ça va
donner c'est non parce que on
s'attendait pas à avoir une plaine comme
ça devant les yeux et avoir un spectacle
finalement permanent en plus il y a eu
le combat combat de ser donc oui je
m'attendais à ça tout à fait avec en
plus la levée du jour c'est parfait la
saison du Bram de mi-septembre à
mi-octobre attire chaque année quelques
visiteurs sur le domaine de chambor sa
réserve de chasse et de faunes sauvage
de plus de 5000 hectares compte entre
700 et 1000 servidés si le SER brame et
bien c'est parce que c'est une façon
d'affirmer sa dominance sur un
territoire mais on sait aussi que
suivant les vocalises il peut y avoir
une forme de de de de brame de séduction
pour pour attirer les biches à la fin de
la saison c'estes malâ qui peuvent peser
de 180 à 220 kg en perdent parfois leur
voix tant ils ont poussé de cris car
pendant un mois il répète jour et nuit
ses affrontements
rituels il y a d'abord cette je vocal
hein qui est le brame ensuite on va
avoir la marche parallèle entre deux
grands mâles qui souhaitent assurer la
dominance sur un même territoire qui
peuvent annoncer déjà le début d'une
tension si aucun des deux ne recule et
bien on peut aller jusqu'au combat de
ser qui vont s'affronter bois contre
bois parfois plusieurs fois même avant
qu'il y en ai un qui recule le pic de la
saison a été atteint la semaine dernière
les affrontements entre les ses baissent
désormais en intensité mais il reste
encore quelques jours pour venir les
observer et surtout les
écouter